we have new details from CBS News chief
legal correspondent Jan Crawford's
exclusive interview with Attorney
General William Bar in Alaska for his
comments about the Justice Department
sparring with Special Counsel robert
muller / legal analysis made headlines
the Attorney General also talked about
evidence it makes him believe top
government officials may have acted
improperly when they authorize
surveillance of President Trump's
campaign this morning we are learning
why Barra went to Alaska for his first
major trip Jan joins us from Washington
with more on that good morning to you
Jan why did he choose to travel so far
well I mean Gale he wants to take a look
at the problems that are plaguing some
of the rest of the country and Alaska's
two US senators had really been urging
him to visit and what he saw there I
mean it prompted him to call Public
Safety and much of the state an
emergency to get to this remote fishing
village in southwest Alaska is a ride by
boat but this is one of the police's
attorney general bill Barr came to see
him here it's good to meet you as he
made his way along the boardwalks that
wind through the village he heard how
the isolation has made the residents
vulnerable in a meeting at the local
school the villages tribal chief pleaded
for help and protection Alaska has the
highest rates of domestic violence and
sexual assault in the United States
three times the national average but an
investigation by the Anchorage Daily
News and ProPublica found one in three
communities in Alaska had no local law
enforcement officers and their sex crime
rates are even higher help can be hours
or a day away someone asks me like why
why are you here why did you pick Alaska
it's because to me my job is to go where
the need is greatest and I think the
need is greatest here these are people
that
are just asking for the basic physical
security and it's not much to ask this
village has new tribal police officers
but with no training their jail is used
primarily as a drunk tank 97% of the
crimes committed by Alaska Natives
involve alcohol or drugs before
traveling to the fishing village bar met
with advocates at one of only two
women's shelters in the entire region
understaffed and overcrowded it's a
common thing
we've got people staying in the living
room and in our clearing in Anchorage
she toured the state crime lab with his
backlog of unprocessed rape kits Barr
met with native leaders from every
region of Alaska and said he's looking
to develop federal state partnerships
I've always been mindful that it's the
responsibility of the Attorney General
to serve all the people of the United
States in every state and in every
community now the Attorney General said
he's hoping to find a broad solution
that will also involve the tribal
governments and today the Justice
Department plans to announce new funding
for Anchorage because of its
disproportionately high crime rates Tony
Jim it seems lack of transportation is
further isolating these remote
communities what other problems are they
facing well I mean I think alcohol I
mean that is a huge problem in these
villages that Alaska Natives they hadn't
even dealt with alcohol until it was
introduced by people from as they say
they're the lower 48 I mean it's banned
in most of those communities but it's
still available its smuggled in it's
sold in some of those towns and as we
mentioned it's a factor in almost all
the cases evolving assault violence and
suicide Jan thank you